- Everyone, this is Gary.
He's our guest star this week.
- Yay, Gary's here, everybody.
Woo-hoo-hoo.
That's fuckin' amazing.
(upbeat music)
- Ah bonjour.
'Cause that's how
I fucking roll.
- Get out, me too.
- Mushroom make
mushroom, mushroom?
Mushroom!
That will never happen.
Are you serious?
- You gotta stop worrying
about what other
people think of you.
That's no way to live
your life, brother.
-Rick!
What the heck?
- You are fucked.
- That's your real name, Rick.
- Yeah
- You're an actor, right.
- You did coke off
the steering wheel.
- You wanna get
an Uzi, Rick?
- Hell yeah, we is.
- Hey, you fucking did this.
(upbeat music)
Yeah, I am a fucking actor.
(gun shots)
- That's so dope.
That's hardcore acting
right there, right?
- Yeah.
- Real acting from a real actor.
- (chuckles) that was good.
(upbeat music)